messieurs bonjour merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rmc france à josé
spinosaures parle d'un renouveau de la
mobilisation est ce que selon vous on y
est
je crois qu'une somme dans le démarrage
de la mobilisation
d'ailleurs j'ai écouté attentivement les
gilet jaune que vous avez interrogé je
pense qu'on est tous sur la même
longueur d'onde c'est à dire que devant
la montée des prix devant les mesures
liberticides qui sont prises il ya
effectivement
je dirai simplement parce que ça fait
trois ans maintenant que nous
manifestons tous les samedis mais il va
y avoir des nouvelles de l'état dans
l'action avec la participation de jeunes
qui se réclament d gilet jaune mais
beaucoup de gens aussi qui serait qu'à
ne pas forcément des gilet jaune et qui
ont des problèmes ce 6e économique très
fort qui va rentrer dans le mouvement
social parce que les gie légende je le
rappelle c'est parti c'est pas une
organisation s'est passé ni quand c'est
un mouvement social qui la fable des
gens de diverses opinions d'ailleurs
vous en avez parlé de certains on n'est
pas forcément d'accord en tous les cas
moi je suis pas forcément d'accord mais
tout ça fait partie du mouvement de
contestation et de colère qu'il y as
contre ce gouvernement est contre le
surtout contre les mesures que prend ce
gouvernement qui sont des mesures qui
vont à l'encontre des intérêts de la
population en commun besser la goutte
d'eau en finalement pour le mouvement
c'est la hausse du prix des carburants
et c'était le même élément déclencheur
il y a trois en automne 2010 8 quel est
donc le constat que vous faites
le constat si vous voulez il est assez
simple on a un élément déclencheur qui a
permis à ce mouvement absolument
légitime de reprendre de l'activité
la question qui se pose c'est bon quoi
il a été suspendu manifestement c'est à
cause de la crise sanitaire et je pense
que cette circonstance c'est un un
élément assez
illustrative de la manière dont le
gouvernement a géré depuis le début ce
les revendications qui sont portés par
ce mouvement qu'il est bon il n'a pas
l'ordre des priorités
bien évidemment quand la crise sanitaire
a éclaté et qu'il a fallu prendre un
certain nombre de mesures par précaution
les gilets jaunes comme toute la
population à respecter les règles qui
devait s'appliquer maintenant que on
entrevoit la fin de la crise et complice
on a cet élément déclencheur
peut-être que le gouvernement devrait
revoir l'ordre de ses priorités
parce que d'annoncer en sortie de crise
sanitaire après un an et demi de
confinement et à quoi qu'il en coûte qui
va provoquer un retour de bâton assez
violent au niveau des finances publiques
au lieu d'annoncer la réforme des
retraites est de 2,2 montré que au bout
d'un an et demi il est toujours dans le
même état d'esprit c'est à dire de
n'écouter personne que lui même je pense
qu'il aurait mieux fait à ce moment là
d'essayer d'apaiser les choses et de
mettre tout le monde autour d'une table
noski spinoza on a interrogé tout à
l'heure un gilet jaune qui font aussi le
look estimé que la situation finale en
était la même aujourd'hui par rapport à
celle qu'il y avait il ya trois ans est
ce que vous faites également ce même
constat
je fais pas tout à fait le même je pense
que la situation est pire qu'avant est
ce que nous avons aujourd'hui des
millions de pauvres de plus c'est le
résultat de la gestion de la crise
sanitaire par mâcon c'est qu'ils
auraient pu ouvrir la population vous
savez que les salariés aient perdu 16 %
de leur salaire à cause d'eux chômage et
technique et donc il ya des difficultés
supplémentaires et qui sont intervenus
et je pense qu'avec le passé nanterre il
s'est mis à dos du des gens qui battu
tommy est donc tout cela c'est qu'il ya
un mécontentement qui gronde encore plus
forte dans le cadre et qui va
certainement se manifester lors des
élections présidentielles et chaîne big
d'ailleurs les gie des jeunes à
s'intéresser au développement politique
pour que une bonne raclée au maquereau
liste aux élections présidentielles qui
arrivent et c'est possible entendant un
pêcheur que peut-on attendre justement
de ce mouvement à la proche de la
présidentielle est ce que justement les
candidats potentiels à cette élection
vont être plus attentifs
plus attentifs moi je ferais là de ce
que je constate par rapport aux
candidatures et aux annonces qui sont
faites par les candidats c'est que on se
retrouve dans une situation où on allait
les candidats à un type connus par
notoriété politique
qui guide le monde entende rien font
comme si ce mouvement n'existait pas et
puis vous avez tous les autres qui eux
paradoxalement alors qu'il porte la voix
d'une grande partie de la population qui
gronde et encore une fois légitimement
n'ont pas accès aux médias donc là je
pense qu'il ya un rôle une
responsabilité du quatrième pouvoir en
france des chaînes de télévision et de
radio de donner la parole à ceux qui
peuvent porter la voix de ceux qui sont
dans la contestation et qui font preuve
d'une endurance particulière moi j'ai
été très touché par le premier chez les
jeunes interviewés par votre confrère
nadège et qui disait ce mouvement c'est
celui de tous et la grogne monte les
gens vont nous rejoindre en fait c'est
ce sursaut collectif qui va permettre de
faire émerger de nouvelles figures dont
pays a largement de ce mois en chantier
monsieur espinosa justement est-ce que
vous aussi vous avez un bon esprit
de ce renouveau en vous le disiez ce
redémarrage à quelques mois de
l'élection présidentielle
il est tout d'abord je ne partage pas le
point de vue que mon collègue vient de
d'abord nous je pense qu'il ya un
candidat qui prennent en compte les
revendications que les gilets jaunes ont
mis en avant par exemple sur le hic le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne
j'avais il ya un candidat qui au nom des
fans cette proposition il a mené
tambours d'autres l'augmentation des
minima sociaux l'augmentation des
salaires et je crois que il ya
aujourd'hui les gilets jaunes doivent
eux faire être encore plus vigilant sur
les programmes de chaque candidat et ils
veulent pouvoir faire la différence
en tant que sur ses finances de les
terminer rapidement votre propos sur la
montée donc de la lutte je crois
qu'effectivement c'est un baiser lennon
qui permet la prise de conscience
aller vers
une prise de position politique qui soit
conséquente avec celle que nous portons
alors monsieur hees qui nous avons parlé
d'un candidat qui manifestement partage
vos revendications on a un problème de
liaison donc on n'a pas entendu le nom
précisément de ce candidat il n'est pas
dernier le monde d'accord donc vous
l'avez fait exprès et sciemment très
bien vous avez le droit parfait entonné
un pêcheur je vais vous donner
rapidement droit de réponse parce qu'on
est pressé par le temps
écoutez ce qui est ou en ma réponse est
très rapide et c'est la beauté du débat
démocratique au sein du mouvement des
filets jaunes monsieur espinosa semble
avoir trouvé un candidat
assez connu et je lui en gelant félicite
pour ma part je pense qu'il ya des
candidats qui sont beaucoup plus proche
des gens et beaucoup plus au courant des
problématiques qui sont soulevées et qui
m'a construit un projet beaucoup plus
sain beaucoup mieux inspiré de ses
revendications et à l'instar de mon
contradicteur la seule chose ce qui me
tient à coeur c'est d'appeler tout le
monde à aller lire les programmes de
tous les pays candidats oui
oui monsieur péchenard très rapidement
vouliez finir peut-être j'en ai terminé
sous robert simmons entendant pêcheurs
vous êtes avocat au barreau de paris
merci avoue josé espinosa gilet jaune
merci à tous les deux messieurs d'avoir
été avec nous en direct soir